the number one thing I do is I don't say
no for them okay everybody says no
they're not gonna like this
they don't care about my kickball team
they don't care that I collect wines
they don't care that I'm in the business
with my brother they do
because where do you keep the balance
once we wanted to persist for the
quality subjective quantity isn't second
question is with and real quick I'm
gonna stay in that consuming value and I
met ironically just mentioned it the
excuse of perfection quality is in the
eye of the beholder everybody's not
creating because right we needs to be
quality that's insecurity or politics in
every organization somebody wants to
make this subjective creative call to
justify their being instead of doing
what I do which is produce confident
scale and let the consumer give me
feedback to make me better I get to
quality by doing quantity like there is
no that sucks isn't behind some Wizard
of Oz saying being like I don't like
this Ohio guy no this is basic I loved
when this gets political they're like
suppressing conservatives are
suppressing little no they're not their
entire business is your attention I know
everything about you right now if I open
up your Instagram and look at it your
explore feed you're a perv I know you
love basketball
I know like this is so funny that people
think there's something going on it's
just propaganda these machines are just
running math against what people are
doing the end don't like it fine you can
move but this is how it's happening this
isn't Russia this isn't China yes like
people are very very very nice
[Music]
a pleasure for you please working boring
business okay and it's mostly
residential existing homes yep growing a
lot reputation yet old school yep and
Google reviews understood Facebook page
we never posed to it cuz enough time
just trying to keep the sales understood
but off of what you said this morning
what kind of content would be reduced
yep because I have thought of stuff in
the past
yep that time to do it like that and all
of that yeah yeah Facebook and LinkedIn
and we're okay smoking like that so and
what kinds of colleges how to's how to
preserve I think design like anything
that you would even conceive if the four
of us had dinner and I'm like tell me
about it people there is no what I'm
trying to get people to understand is
instead of thinking about what put out
everything and see what they want not
what we think is right it's finding
right instead of being right a million
different things a million different
yeah you could even make content about
being in a business with a sibling and
that may resonate with somebody on
LinkedIn no really it's a very like I
think it's actually potentially your
biggest pillar of content you guys
talking about how to make a family
business work we'll have a whole group
of people become aware of you who then
happened to also need [ __ ] flooring
another thing to your to space got it
what consumer can assume it's
commoditize where you all your come on
this [ __ ] that goes wrong right you
would think I can go higher any but I'm
but I'm telling you I'm telling you this
doesn't cost as much money and so you
should put out content about it is man
and it doesn't have to be over produced
just using that at first it gives you
indicators what are you doing
construction okay and so what my
question is is should I
and expound upon the business and I run
the construction business
yes founder but I run the business
should I expand upon the followers I
already have using me yes a it ok versus
make a whole new one I would do both do
both yes ok but you have leverage with
what you have right now ok yes
personally 100% ok don't say no for the
audience
ok ok that's it the number the number
one thing I do is I don't say no for
them ok everybody says no they're not
gonna like this
they don't care about my kickball team
they don't care that I collect wine they
don't care that I'm in the business with
my brother they do care ok and it makes
you basically more approachable Oh
hundred percent normal person 100
percent
you might be walking through like Browns
like oh yeah you know they never know
what it is that makes sense
all right one question you're a high
energy guy how to keep your energy
I think I've come to realize its
gratitude gratitude is my fuel I'm
grateful
it's like I'm alive yeah I keep things
very basic as long as my family's
healthy it's hard for me to get down
it really is I've really got a very
old-school perspective and so I'm just
grateful you know no guys it's Gary Vee
again you know you saw my impromptu rant
a couple of weeks ago I'm sitting some
real love to all employees at the
airport I travel a lot I see a lot
they're just underrated they just are I
just don't understand the lack of
gratitude of the traveling community the
reality is it is the most remarkable
technology in the world you goat in a
metal device and you land at another
place in record time of course there's
going to be some delays and things of
that nature gratitude and kindness
always makes a trip better what are you
looking for just want to ask you quite
exciting things for Millennials trying
to manage everything learning how to
manage everything how do you manage
everything Gary everything I'm not over
judging myself that's the actual answer
bro
appreciate it it's hard to manage
nobody's managing everything every day
it's about lack of judgment on oneself
patience that's why I push it because
when you think you're gonna actually
work for next 80 years
all of a sudden eight days and eight
months does it mean so much praise David
thank you so much
so it's soaked my industry so heavily
regular I can't like somebody's post
because it's considered a recommendation
I understand so I like you know you
can't listen I'm deep in this you can't
like somebody it's post who's making
some sort of claim or is an or is within
your field so but if it just like cheese
you do what you do understand that you
could make content around soccer and
that could be the gateway to like you
said interview local community there's
so many ways to navigate this I've been
working on a deck that I'm gonna put on
LinkedIn I've liked how to create
content in a regulated industry look
forward I'm gonna put out in the fall
but honestly it's a paradigm shift
instead of dwelling on what you can't do
which is what you can't do
start the process of truck I couldn't
ship the 39 of the 50 states when I
started my wine company because the laws
instead of just sitting there every day
like everybody else in crying I [ __ ]
crushed the 11 states I could
[Music]
so a lot of people fighting for
attention on gaming content and like
passive viewing content rightly how do
we make our thing and I'm not like
asking you to answer this to it
obviously it's content at scale that's
contextual to the moment right it's
making 747 pieces of content and tic toc
that understands what content on tic toc
works the end yeah it's it's it's this
it's kind of like how do I get into
incredible shape seven days a week I
want you to eat properly and I want you
to work out properly you know like the
thesis is simple the execution is hard
yeah but that is the thesis literally
like we're gonna freelance out a lot of
[ __ ] in terms of concentration again in
this think of that the same way I've
told you to think about Twitter
the sooner I know it's an overhead
there's about you know the sooner it
becomes yours the better yeah because
you know this the scariest part is
social media marketing works
uncomfortably well the problem is 99% of
people claim they know it don't write
that is the craziest thing right out
it's so right but the amount of clowns
compared to actual executors is so out
of control because the judges don't know
how to judge it which is created the
ability for so many clowns to run wild
but no I mean incredible I mean you saw
the news coming out of VidCon
that was the place that people really
needed to be at 10:00 what did you say
it's like training wheels for you to my
point on snapchat that last two that
have popped snapped and actually I'm
sorry Instagram to pay attention in su
mo filters
snapchat with the way it kind of worked
also with filters and in really a are
first and then tick-tock with music the
last three social networks that popped
are helping people create got it got it
so that's what I'm thinking about like
what else helps somebody create the
music like someone's like I don't know
what to do take something that's popular
music wise and it doesn't matter what
you do you got a shot it's no different
than sampling [ __ ] classics you know
like did he did it better than anybody
he ever did it a bad boy I'm just gonna
sample the classics from the last
generation and reboot it and get great
talent to go over it music just makes me
and Matt have a chance you know so
that's what that's how I see it I see
the last three social network platforms
that have come out have assisted in the
concentration so my argument is if
you're the kids sitting in your basement
right now Sally and you're 13 and you're
like I'm the next Mark Zuckerberg it
might be a good idea to think about what
training wheels can I put on my app that
helps somebody
hey guys it's Gary
I stole Matt's phone he doesn't know he
clearly knows what's your favorite thing
about that
another funny how people don't want to
learn though to your weather give this
advice and then come up afterwards be
like so what do I do now go hire
somebody or at least that would be
better
kugel is your mom there are no mysteries
there are no mysteries no one exam but
the answers are they don't want to do it
it's no different than dieting yeah well
they don't want to do it right that's
true so is that a lack of intrinsic
motivation I don't think so
it's a disconnect between words and
actions yeah that's true between
intentions it's it's a disconnect
between the narrative one is putting out
to the world and never themselves I
really want this or that you really
don't want a hundred percent hundred
like I [ __ ] really wanted it I gave
up my [ __ ] money like like you know
like I can never through all my passion
actually describe how [ __ ] up I played
it yeah
I mean it I [ __ ] up like it was too
ridiculous
I did nothing I mean I just I over
corrected I want every medicine it's a
hundred percent my brother's always
gonna be [ __ ] like you're gonna die this
is it this is what it looks like it's
not a scalpel I got a [ __ ]
overcorrect to end up anywhere near
where I want to go I [ __ ] right and I
might die I wasn't so yeah not that's
there to me but but but but it's kind of
like being a [ __ ] caterpillar like
like I'm gonna be a [ __ ] butterfly
like there is this is the destiny right
like there nothing else is interesting
this with death is better than not this
right without now is it what's the
alternative
this is a better outcome I'd rather live
happy
[Music]
I'd rather be happy going from Columbus
to New York
[Music]
so we're waiting here in the next
location for the next meeting and Gary's
just hidden behind some cars across the
street wonder if you can see us oh this
is a short little segment
you know episode that we like to call
the daily rock it's early in the morning
and we're walking through the hotel
lobby the wild rock looks a little tired
doesn't he
a little bit on the sleep beside ladies
and gentlemen I really hope this makes
the dailyvee episode hamed yeah it will
aha the daily roux notice the rock in
his wild environment here still has
width still as wit
[Music]